the time when your Secretary of State  you said Breck says may not happen it  could be walked back that was two years  ago have you changed your mind you think  it's inevitable now well I think what I  what I gleaning from friends in  Parliament and elsewhere is that the  dynamics of what has unfolded probably  now make it more likely that there'll be  some kind of brexit what kind of rack  said is yet obviously very much up for  grabs but clearly Ireland's border  challenge in the north has got to be  understood by people and and we we do  not want to see a restoration of a hard  border and that conscription czar that  may or may not be available